there are a couple of of choices so
ultimately what I'd like to understand
is how attention works in a human
because I'm a human but the problem is
that for doing experiments humans are
sometimes in many ways not the ideal
preparation they're not the ideal
subjects and the reason of course is
that we don't have access to what's
going on inside the human brain at the
level of resolution that one might like
and furthermore we don't have the means
of manipulating that activity within a
human in a way that we can actually
probe what's really going on so although
one preparation that has been and is
remains really useful for studying
attention as the human if we want sort
of a finer grain understanding we have
to go to so-called non-human models of
attention and there are several the
dominant one is the primate monkey the
monkey the primate model the monkey and
the reason for studying a monkey of
course is that monkeys are fairly
similar to humans in a lot of ways their
brain seems similar their evolutionary
evolutionarily quite close but in
practice there are also limitations with
monkeys and so for my research we've
actually moved to rodents and there are
a couple of advantages of studying
attention in rome's but the first
advantage is that we can scale up and
study dozens and and potentially from
hundreds of rodents in parallel in a way
that you can't really do in a monkey and
practice the way that people work with
monkeys is they they train a monkey for
a year or two and then they perform
experiments on that monkey for many
years because monkeys are incredibly
valuable so the kinds of information
that you can get out from a monkey is
really useful but you can't really do a
lot of experimental manipulations the
way you can in other kinds of
preparations so with rodents what we do
is we focus on tasks that we can train
the rats and mice to perform our
training time is
typically a few weeks and then what we
can do is explore what happens in their
brain after they've learned to perform
an attention task on top of that what we
can do is we can manipulate the neural
activity within a rodents brain at a
level of precision that at this point we
really can't achieve in a monkey and
certainly not in a human with a human we
study groups neural activity in patches
that are you know consist of hundreds of
thousands of neurons in monkeys we can
study single neurons at a time but we
can't really manipulate whole parts of
the circuit and in rodents we can
actually now target subsets of neurons
based on how they're wired up and so
that's what we're able to do now in in
the rodent preparation we've designed a
special behavioral box so that we can
actually train runs to perform
attentional tasks in parallel the whole
thing is computer controlled the
starting point for all these tasks is a
rat that's been trained to stick its
nose into the center port of a
three-port box so what you see is
looking down on a box the rat sticks its
nose into the center port that breaks an
LED beam that signals to a computer that
ah the rat has entered the center port
and now we can program the computer to
deliver whatever kind of stimuli we want
auditory in fact one of my colleagues
uses it to present olfactory stimuli
visual stimuli but in our case it's
auditory stimuli the rat breaks the
center beam in this example what you see
is that that triggers the computer to
present either a low-frequency sound or
a high-frequency sound when it presents
a low-frequency sound the rat goes to
one of the ports and then he gets a
reward of a small amount of water if he
breaks the beam and it's the other sound
that's presented he goes to the other
port and gets his reward and as you can
see the rat really understands what he's
supposed to do he sticks his nose in
goes in one way sticks his nose in goes
the other way he's going as fast as he
can to pick up his rewards now when you
actually what you actually hear
on this video is that the low frequency
and high frequency sounds are both
masked by some white noise that's to
make it more challenging for the rat and
the the other thing is that the hearing
range of a rat is shifted from the
hearing range of a human so humans rain
here from about 20 Hertz to about 20
kilohertz rats here from about 1
kilohertz to the ultrasonic what is for
us ultrasonic 70 kilohertz so the
low-frequency sound for the rat is
something that's sort of on the upper
end of what we hear a few kilohertz I
think it's 5 kilohertz and the high
frequency sound in this case is beyond
what we can actually hear and so what
you actually hear is either white noise
alone or white noise plus a low
frequency sound oh and that's what you
see so how do we use this to study
attention so this is the starting point
for all our tests this just demonstrates
that the rat can take sound stimuli and
use it to guide his behavior left and
right we have more complicated tasks
where what we do is we have the rat
attend to a particular aspect of the
sound stimulus so one of the studies
that we've done recently is the ability
of a rat to focus in on particular
moments in time in other words we we
train the rat to guide his temporal
expectation as to when a target occurs
so in the other example what you see is
that the rat sticks his nose in and he's
presented with a series of distractor
tones baby pppp pppp and then he goes
either left or right based on whether a
target sound which is a warble verb is
either high frequency or low frequency
or and what makes it an attentional task
is that we've trained the rat to expect
the target to be either early in the
trial after one or two of the
distractors or late in the trial after
about 10 or 15 of the distractor
that is after about a second second and
a half in the center port and in that
way we can guide the moment at which he
expects the target to occur and the idea
is that he kind of ramps up his
attention for the the target sound and
what we found is that when he ramps up
his attention in this way is the speed
with which he responds to the target is
faster than if the target comes
unexpectedly and that's something that
we find in humans as well so that's what
I'm in fact the hallmarks of attention
is an improvement in performance as
measured either by his speed or accuracy
and the other thing we found is that
there are neurons in the auditory cortex
whose activity is specially enhanced
when he expects the target compared with
when that same target is presented but
it comes in an unexpected moment so we
think that that is beginning to be the
neural correlates of the enhanced
performance that we've seen